Today, Michael Kinch, who is associate vice
chancellor at Washington University in St.
Louis and also author of Between Hope and
Fear, which is a History of Vaccines.
So great to have you on today.
Thanks for the opportunity so we could start
in so many different places, but let's just
maybe start with something that's a big topic
of discussion right now.
We've seen sort of different numbers stated
about what the goal should be in terms of
the percentage of Americans or of global citizens.
But maybe we'll start with Americans that
need to be vaccinated in order for the U.S.
to approximate what would be called herd immunity.
And, of course, there's a number of input
factors that determine what this number should
be, how contagious something is, how effective
the vaccines are, and all of these other things.
What's what are the sort of the most important
things we should be thinking about now in
terms of the variance, in terms of vaccine
hesitancy, all of these different input factors
for if there is this this one number that
we should be looking at as as the sort of
threshold.
Yes, and herd immunity is a term that it's
actually been misidentified and misused, particularly
by the previous administration, in a nutshell,
it's the likelihood that if you're someone
who is susceptible, let's say you were a cancer
patient who had chemotherapy to knock down
your immune system, what is the likelihood
that you will encounter someone in your vicinity
that might affect you?
And that number for sars-cov-2, the current
source of the pandemic has been creeping upwards.
It started at about 70 percent.
And it looks like today it's probably between
80 and 85 percent, in part because these new
variants, the British variant of the South
African variant, not to mention the Brazilian
variant that hasn't gotten as much press,
are far more communicative.
So I think we need to be shooting for eighty
five percent.
And from a realistic standpoint, that means
that we need to have probably 90 to 95 percent
of the population protected because again,
some people will have had cancer therapy,
rheumatoid arthritis treatment.
There are simply old, very old or very young.
And they may be immunized, but the immunization
may not take.
And so we're going to have to go in excess
of that 80 to 85 percent number in order to
assure that we finally get this virus behind
us.
Now, this this may be a silly question, but
I've not heard it addressed head on necessarily.
When we talk about these numbers, I presume
we're talking about the entire population.
If you are not including people below a certain
age, at least initially, don't we really need
one hundred percent of eligible adults?
Because there are so many people under 18
or 16, which are the ages that the Fizer and
Moderna vaccines respectively have been tested
on?
Don't we really need every adult vaccinated?
We do and essentially, again, that eighty
five percent number alone means that we need
that the vaccines are being tested in pediatric
populations, but we don't have the data yet.
Right.
And so every adult, in order to protect your
children and your grandchildren really needs
to be vaccinated soon.
And as you mentioned, it's not just here in
the US, it's around the world, because when
you look at it, as we've seen, we have variants
coming out of South Africa and other countries.
And that means that someone in one country
or a population of one country that decides
not to be vaccinated could actually jeopardize
the rest of the planet.
On on today's program, one of the things we
looked at was a new study that looked at the
current level of vaccine hesitancy in the
American population.
The good topline news is that the 60 65 percent
hesitancy of May 20 20 has been reduced dramatically.
It's now down, according to this latest study,
about a third of the country.
When you slice and dice different groups,
three groups that are particularly or disproportionately
vaccine hesitant when it comes to this vaccination
are among political lines, Republicans among
racial lines, black Americans and among educational
lines, those without a college degree for
different reasons.
These three groups seem to be hesitant of
the vaccine for different reasons.
What historically have been some of the most
effective ways to get more buy in to mass
vaccination campaigns?
There are two things.
One is that we need to be 100 percent transparent,
both in what we know and what we don't know.
We're not here to sell a used car.
We're here to get past the pandemic.
And so I think that we need to convey when
there is information that we don't know about,
we need to convey that.
But we also need to convey what we do know
and we need to stop rumors.
There have been rumors that are completely
unsubstantiated about causing lack of female
fertility or lack of male fertility and many
other things.
But we also need to respect that there are
certain populations of people, for example,
black Americans that were subjected, for example,
to the Tuskegee experiments.
Right.
And that means that they're hesitant about
many different standardized medical procedures.
And we need to then explain to them, here
is what we know about it and why you're not
being an experimental subject.
But this is important.
And that gets to the second thing we can do
to minimize the anti-tax movement, and that
is to people it's been shown will be more
amenable to being vaccinated as someone that
they knew was vaccinated and if it went well.
And so the more that we get into those populations,
the better it should turn out.
The one of the concerns I have and I'm wondering
whether you share it, is that there are many
articles that, from my perspective, are underselling
the benefits of in particular the two vaccines
that are approved right now.
And sometimes you will see maybe not headlines,
but like some headlines that will say even
when vaccinated, nobody can do anything differently.
Everything has to remain the same for a very
long time.
And when you sometimes get into the details
or look at the blogs of immunologists as an
example, you will actually see much more interesting
information like, listen, there is going to
be some risk no matter what, but a small group
of vaccinated adults, 10 days pass dose number
two is at very low risk to do an indoor gathering.
In particular, if everybody works from home,
you know, more sort of like meat on the bone
about there really are some differences.
And this is a game changer and it will be
more of one as more people get vaccinated.
Do you think my concern is warranted about
the underselling of the vaccines?
It is, although, again, we don't want to come
across as selling a used car, right, but I
think you look at these vaccines are truly
miraculous.
The magnitude of efficacy and frankly, safety
as well is far beyond what any of us thought
a year ago we would be able to achieve, especially
within this time frame.
And I would say it's better than the Apollo
mission.
That being said, we are underselling it.
And I think that the proper way to address
this, what you just mentioned, which is very
valid, is to say, look, we don't yet know
after you're vaccinated whether you might
be able to communicate virus to others.
And we want to communicate to people.
The last thing that you want to do is to unintentionally
infect your grandparents, your children, your
grandchildren.
And so just to be safe, let's keep up those
safety measures until we have established
herd immunity.
And let's be clear what herd immunity really
means.
And I think most reasonable people will say,
oh, if I'm protecting my neighbors by doing
this, that's a great reason to do it.
Not that it's this onerous thing that we have
to continue to do.
You were talking about the Republican pushback
to vaccination.
This is simply a continuation of the denial
that the pandemic was real, the denial that
the masks are effective and we have to get
past that and say, look, independent of what
your political views are.
Here's what the science tells us.
What is the best way for someone to accurately
sort of pass as you talk about so many rumors
every single day, there's something the medicine,
a vaccine doesn't work against the South African
variant.
Oh, it does.
But it just is more borderline in terms of
the immunity versus being more robust against
the UK variant.
And maybe that's not true.
We need to get to one level of herd immunity
versus another.
And then the next day we find out the number
is actually different for the average person,
particularly people not like me who do this
for a living, but people who have other jobs
where they can't follow this stuff necessarily
that that closely.
What's the best way to stay up on the sort
of top line realities are about cases, about
deaths, about vaccination treatment, et cetera.
Well, now that the Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention is under capable hands, again,
I think that you can go back to trusting them.
Frankly, we had the best public health group
on the planet until this pandemic broke out
and they lost a lot of their credibility.
And I, frankly, was telling people, don't
listen to CDC because they weren't giving
the right information.
But I would say if you had one go to reliable
place, it would be the CDC.
Otherwise, don't Google go, for example, to
Mayo Clinic or go to whatever your local hospital
has to say.
Look what they have to say, Google and Twitter.
I mean, one of the amazing things is that
if you look at the antibiotics movement, not
just for this pandemic, but MMR and other
vaccines, it is just comforting to know that
about 85 to 90 percent of the tweets that
are anti vax are coming from Russian troll
farms and all they are doing is really undermining
and their intent is to undermine belief in
authorities.
And so I have not naive belief in authorities,
but especially the CDC.
It's turned itself around just in the past
few weeks, still got a lot of room to make
up, but go to the major universities, other
places that are not making money or profiting
in any way from this.
For the most part, the pharma companies have
actually been surprisingly transparent.
There have been some exceptions.
And I've been a big critic of the exceptions.
And we need to be critics of the exceptions.
And but I would say that most people so far
have come together and been mostly responsible
when it comes to vaccines per day.
When Joe Biden was just days from being sworn
in, he was talking about a million a day for
100 days.
Of course, at the time, the approved vaccines
are are two doses, meaning you're talking
about vaccinating 50 million people were now
hopefully getting closer to the approval of
the JMJ vaccine, which will be a one dose.
And then there's potentially more more vaccines
coming when when you're looking at this.
I mean, it seems to me that with a third vaccine,
two and a half to three million doses a day,
total is is reasonable, which seems like it
would be a major accomplishment.
But we're still talking about months there
in the best of cases until everybody can get
vaccinated.
What sort of numbers are you looking at?
I mean, I think the two key numbers to remember
are three hundred and fifty million Americans.
Right.
Which if we forget the JMJ vaccine for a minute,
that means seven hundred million doses, which
is a lot.
And this is a brand new technology.
But then the other number is seven and a half
billion humans, which then means 15 billion
doses.
And again, this isn't over until it's completely
over.
Now, I believe and hope that the JMJ vaccine
is likely to be approved based on what we've
seen.
Its efficacy numbers are, again, very impressive.
They're not quite up to the Marnay vaccine
numbers, but at least it could get someone
some transient protection, if you will.
And future studies can determine, well, maybe
someone who got one vaccine will need a boost
of another.
But I the most remarkable thing about the
vaccine numbers is not necessarily just the
magnitude of efficacy, which is exceeding
at this point ninety five percent.
And based on the Israeli study, it may be
closer to ninety nine point five percent.
Right.
But it's the fact that the disease severity
is greatly reduced and people, frankly, are
not dying or getting severe disease.
And that's where we want to be.
If you're stuck with feeling bad for a few
days or getting a cold, which most of coronaviruses
cause a cold, that's infinitely better than
having to be intubated and, Lord forbid, pass
away or have your relatives do.
So, I would say the big numbers now are we've
got to ramp up production.
The need now, the concern now is not anti
vax.
The concern is manufacturing and making sure
that the manufacturing quality still stays
high.
And that's where, again, FDA has been very
consistent and fantastic about doing that.
There have been some some preference based
in some cases almost on accidental circumstances
that have surfaced, which suggests then again,
I want to be careful to make clear that we're
talking about something we're still learning
about, which suggests that in some cases,
if at the time that the second dose would
be given, you just kept waiting, you would
get a very close level of protection to what
you get from the second dose plus seven to
14 days.
Is that an interesting path that you think
needs to be looked at in terms of possibly
being able to expand the number of people
inoculated with the vaccines were expecting
to have?
If the data show it, I think that we run a
risk, there was there was discussion about
giving everybody one shot.
Right.
And even if it falls outside the window that
was done in the clinical trials, giving them
a later shot, we just frankly don't have the
data to say whether that's useful or not.
And the situation we don't want to end up
in is that we give everyone one shot and one
shot turns out to be insufficient and we have
to start and turn around and begin afresh.
Right now, everyone needs two shots, even
if you already had one and we just don't that
we have to be guided by the data.
We the last administration was frustrating
because they didn't seem to want to track
any data.
And this administration, I think, is open
to it.
There's going to be pressure to hit these
artificial numbers.
I would say 100 million and one hundred days
is great.
All I care about is as many as can be safely
done.
That's the number we need to get.
And hopefully that will be well in excess
of one hundred million, no doubt about it.
Yeah.
And two million last Saturday and two million
last Sunday.
Certainly our great, great, great numbers
to start seeing.
We've been speaking with Michael Kench, author
of Between Hope and Fear A History of Vaccines,
also associate vice chancellor at Washington
University in St. Louis.
Such a pleasure having you on.
I really appreciate your time.